summer fun is here but we can't forget
summer dangers intermountain healthcare
the sponsors of this next segment remind
us how to take care of our elderly
community in the heat
[Music]
my name is dr audrey sue cruz i am an
internal medicine physician here at
intermountain mygen
clinic we specialize in patients who are
65 and older the senior population we
also see younger patients as well
so i work at the blue diamond clinic
which is where we are right now and we
service the southwest area of las vegas
so it's getting really hot now during
the summer time and of course every year
it gets really really hot here in las
vegas and what we want our patients to
know especially in the senior population
is how to keep themselves safe during
this really difficult very hot time in
las vegas so now as the temperatures are
starting to rise over 100 degrees we
want our patients to know
the things to look out for in terms of
dehydration and heat related illnesses
things to look out for for dehydration
include really high and fast heartbeat
feeling dry sweating profusely
having muscle cramps and overall just
not feeling well and things to avoid are
staying outside for long periods of time
we definitely want our patients to carry
around water bottles with them at all
times
and you don't need to wait until you're
thirsty to drink water definitely if
it's you're already thirsty that means
it might be a bit too late so definitely
keep drinking water throughout the day
find yourself shade when you are outside
try not to be outside for long periods
of time and then also find cooling
centers in the community where you can
sit inside and cool down so libraries
shopping malls grocery stores things
like that where you can make sure that
your body temperature
can decrease a little bit and in terms
of drinking water a really good
recommendation is drinking half your
body weight in ounces of fluid so for
example if someone were
to weigh 100 pounds we would recommend
that they drink at least 50 ounces of
fluid per day we also recommend eating a
proper diet lots of fruits and veggies
and also avoiding too much strenuous
activity especially during the summer we
still want our patients to exercise but
definitely try to avoid too much
strenuous activity
outside so there are several types of
heat related illnesses including mild
issues like heat cramps or heat rash but
there are more extreme cases too that
include heat exhaustion and even heat
stroke which can be fatal so some
symptoms for heat exhaustion and heat
stroke can include heavy sweating
cold pale and clammy skin
muscle cramps dizziness fast weak pulse
and even nausea and vomiting so if a
patient has any of these symptoms it's
important to rest in a cool shaded
location and drink plenty of water
a more severe symptom of heat stroke is
a body temperature of 103 degrees and
higher and in that cases a person should
cool down very quickly either in an ice
bath or using ice packs and they should
seek medical attention so one tip that
we have is to try to do any physical
activities away from concrete or
artificial turf these surfaces tend to
soak up more of the sun's energy and can
increase the heat in any area by several
degrees we encourage people to plan
ahead and know that in temperatures like
these people may have to deviate from
their normal routine to avoid
dehydration and heat illness if you have
any questions at all about heat-related
illness or how to keep yourself safe
please feel free to talk to your
physician we here at intermountain mygen
clinic are here for you come see us
and i just wanted to remind everyone in
the community to please check in on your
elderly family members elderly neighbors
and elderly friends
thanks again to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit the website on your
screen
intermountainhealthcare.org slash nevada
we'll be right